russia insists it won't invade ukraine
but the u.s says the signs suggest
otherwise
shelling intensifies in eastern ukraine
and diplomatic talks from moscow to
de-escalate appear to be going nowhere
so is war inevitable
this is inside story
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program i'm
muhammad zhum the u.s has again warned
that russia could invade ukraine at any
moment secretary of state anthony
blinken told the united nations security
council that moscow may manufacture an
excuse to attack
russia's deputy foreign minister called
the allegations baseless
beyond the war of words fighting in
eastern ukraine is worsening
russian-backed separatists and ukrainian
government forces accuse each other of
stepping up artillery and mortar fire in
the contested donbass region charles
stratford has more from pavlo pill in
southeastern ukraine
we've been speaking to people in this
village they indeed say that in the last
couple of days there has been an
escalation of shelling they were telling
us that they heard a shelling this
morning between around five and eight in
the morning it was the same
yesterday
and it's been a similar kind of story um
along various areas of the 420 kilometer
front line in the last 24 hours the
ukrainian military
this morning saying that shelling had
was ongoing or had continued overnight
the people you speak to
most of them do not believe that there
will be any further russian escalation
but as we've been reporting they are
exhausted they are tired of this
conflict they have very little faith in
their own governments certainly on the
ukrainian side to deal with this crisis
but at the same time very little trust
in what vladimir putin has said so
despite it being calm here today the
situation certainly
remains remains tense
ukraine's defense minister says he
believes the risk of a russian invasion
is low at this stage but insists the
army is prepared
i would like to underline that we
constantly face provocations
shelling cyber attacks dangerous
maneuvers by aviation the lowering of
our mobile coverage our task is not to
do what the russian federation pushes us
to do we will repel but keep our head
cool
around 150 000 russian soldiers have
been deployed near the ukrainian border
moscow says it has pulled some of them
back but the u.s and its western allies
in nato don't believe that
russia's president vladimir putin is due
to oversee nuclear military drills on
saturday the kremlin denies the
exercises will inflame tensions
diplomatic efforts intensified on friday
ukraine is the main talking point at the
munich security conference in germany
the u.s president and vice president are
also holding discussions with european
and nato leaders
you know it's ironic that
what mr putin
did not want to see happen was a
stronger nato
on his flank
and that's exactly what he will see
going forward
all right let's bring in our guests in
washington dc we have william taylor he
is vice president russia and europe at
the u.s institute of peace and a former
u.s ambassador to ukraine from odessa
hannah celeste director of security
programs at the think tank ukrainian
prison
and in moscow by skype is pavel
felgenhauer he's an independent defense
and military analyst a very warm welcome
to you all and thanks so much for
joining us today on inside story uh
william let me start with you from your
perspective at this stage is war
inevitable
war is not inevitable uh mr putin has a
decision
uh he can invade in which case there
will be a war a major war in europe
first time since world war ii or
he can decide to negotiate
that option has been on the table
he's expressed some interest in this at
least in some aspects of negotiation
so he has a choice uh war is not
inevitable
pavel the last we've heard from russian
president putin was in a news conference
a short time ago where he said that we
are ready to follow negotiation track
with nato on security guarantees what
exactly does that mean
well russia has issued its position that
russia is totally unhappy with the
present security arrangements in europe
and wants to
rewrite them and write them rewrite them
dramatically
moscow's demand
several key demands that nate girl sees
any uh further expansion including
ukraine but not only ukraine uh native
american and other western militaries
and infrastructure are withdrawn from
former east european central european
nations to the positions of
1997
and the new attack
weapons are not placed anywhere near
russia's border where russia would not
like them that's more or less the thing
the west is not agreeing to that that's
what moscow also says the russian
leadership the russian
the western response is not adequate and
so that means there's going to be
continued military and diplomatic
pressure
but that means also right now i see
indications that the
russian military are beginning to step
down from the present super high state
of readiness they're stepping down it's
not yet uh totally conclusive but
apparently yes so what band we were
going to have that we summed the
escalation at least the military
de-escalation though the
tension the diplomatic tension and
actually the threats will continue
hannah as you heard paul then he was
talking about the fact that one of the
main demands uh from russia is that
ukraine not ever joined nato this has
been so much a part of this crisis i
want to ask you from your vantage point
what's the sentiment right now in
ukraine with regards to ukraine possibly
joining nato in the future is this
something that's important to ukrainians
are most of them
uh against this idea or for this idea
uh thank you for your question there are
several things to emphasize first of all
in 2013 ukraine already had a status of
de facto neutral state not claiming the
membership in nato and it didn't stop
the russian federation to enact crimea
and to start aggression in donbass so
the neutral status of ukraine not
joining nato is not something that
really changing the future of
sovereignty of ukraine from the russian
perspective it just became a nice slogan
to preserve in terms of support uh in
2013 it was just certain percent now uh
the new polls been published just few
days ago 62 percent of ukrainians
support ukrainian uh membership in nato
so you can imagine how the russian
aggression did completely opposite they
just raised the support among the
population is it critical for ukraine uh
we need to understand that it's not
something technical we are speaking
about the choice of people the choice of
country and ukraine is choice choosing
to be with the best in terms of security
in terms of values principles and
democracy so in this way it's not about
ukraine joining nato or joining european
union or any other country it is about
the sovereign choice of the state to
enter those military alliances that we
would like plus don't forget that the
statements of the russian preparation in
december was not only about ukraine the
de facto asked that nato would reject
all those membership that happened after
1992
so it means all eastern european
countries should either demilitarize or
just left the nato if to read those
proposals william russia is saying that
president vladimir putin is going to
personally oversee military drills
involving strategic forces on saturday
at a time when tensions are soaring what
message is the u.s going to take away
from this
i guess the message uh that we will hear
um is that uh president putin is uh
willing to and uh continue the high
crisis mode
um
again uh he is trying to intimidate
president putin is trying to intimidate
president zelinski
president biden nato into giving
concessions along the lines that pavel
described and
so far president zielinski and president
biden and nato have not agreed at all
they have rejected these concessions
they are not
intending and they've given no
indication that they want to
give these concessions to president
putin so president putin's military
buildup his attendance at these nuclear
drills are all intended to intimidate
and so far president lenski and
president biden have not been
intimidated pavel you said earlier that
there is going to be at least from your
perspective there is going to be
de-escalation or the de-escalation is
happening of course nato
has said repeatedly that there's no
meaningful evidence that there is any
de-escalate de-escala de-escalation
steps being taken right now i want to
ask you how long can president putin
keep the russian military in this kind
of a heightened state
and i don't think that very long but of
course uh i mean the escalation the
buildup of battle readiness took over
two months at least
and so the and now right now the russian
military entire russian militia not only
around ukraine but in the entirety of
the nation in the pacific in the
north sea in the
mediterranean and
all the in the nuclear uh deterrent
nuclear strategic forces all are cocked
and
and ready
cocked and voted i would say uh so uh
standing down from that readiness will
take also at least the mouth most likely
more
and that should begin now more or less i
see early signs and actually this
exercise strategic new queer exercise
happening tomorrow is also an indication
that there's a
standing down beginning because
traditionally such exercises when the
president sort of sits together with his
top military chiefs and gives orders to
fire strategic intercontinental missiles
and some are actually fired of course
without nuclear weapons and into
aiming at russian test grounds in
kamchatka and other places of russia
that's always the combination and the
end of a big kind of military buildup i
mean that's a simulation that we had to
build up we had a crisis we had maybe
a regional war it ends up in the nuclear
holocaust which will be kind of
reenacted tomorrow and that's and that's
all more or less begins to de-escalate
that's the good news the bad news is
that if there won't be any uh meaningful
and comprehensive
resolution of the underlying political
and security problems somewhere and they
don't know six months seven months we're
going to see something happening the
same again the same crisis the same
buildup and maybe even it will be worse
william i saw you nodding along some of
what pablo was saying there looked like
he wanted to jump in so go ahead
thank you no i agree with paul that
if even if
president putin
does
go to negotiations that is if he decides
not to invade ukraine
even if he makes that decision
our view is he won't give up
he will continue to want to dominate
ukraine uh he will continue to want to
try to reabsorb ukraine into the russian
world
into the russian empire uh that that
desire that almost obsession with
ukraine will not go away and so pavel's
right
the west will have to continue to
support ukraine militarily
diplomatically financially
for a long time so that it can proceed
on its own desired direction
so as as hana has said
ukraine is a sovereign country gets to
decide and if it's decided to go towards
europe that's its decision and the
united states will continue to help
ukraine on that path
hannah the donbass region has
significant russian minority russia has
said the people there feel more russian
but there are some surveys that have
disputed this
would the possibility of seeding
parts of those two regions or the
entirety of the regions donetsk and
luhansk or perhaps allowing more russian
influence there would that do anything
to de-escalate
uh mohammed several things first of all
clarifications and what's never been
russian my family is from there so i
have all the right to speak about this
don't mix the uh um russian and russian
speaking russian speaking it just
historically happened in several regions
of ukraine because of the soviets uh uh
but it started even earlier for several
prohibitions of use of ukrainian
language however ethnically donbass is
quite a multi-ethnic with the dominant
ukrainian population and before 2014 we
never had any issues ethnic issues not
in denver not in my uh city of odessa
where i live now that's also by russians
very often are called the russian city
nobody knows from where it's more of the
historical myths that russia have been
very successful in uh bringing however
definitely those regions were under
heavy russian information influence and
political influence for quite a time
even before 2014. so that gives some
difficulties there for the future and
also about the escalation i would like
to be the same optimistic as pavilion
trust me i'm the first one who would
like to see the escalation but the real
situation demonstrate completely
different first of all the intelligence
services just
confirmed that additional force has been
uh brought to the border of ukraine in
the last few days the temporary bridge
has been built near the rivers plus the
last two days you have the significant
violation of the ceasefire in donbass
just yesterday 50
uh uh towns been uh shelled and
even targeted kindergartens and schools
so mostly civilian places
and two-thirds of these were with the
use of the weapons prohibited by the
minsk agreements so for five years they
should be withdrawn very far from the
contact line so these is definitely not
demonstrating the escalating plus what
we see uh in continuation for what my
colleague said that even if this big
military buildup would be over what is
next what is next we're already
witnessing first of all it is the
intense cyber attacks against ukraine
just for the last months you have two
huge cyber attacks against banks against
the governmental institutions in ukraine
and it is the economic blockade or the
maritime blockade since sunday we have
the northern black sea being blocked by
the russian military exercises when uh
ships for example cannot cross the care
straight for more than 60 hours and the
airports of odessa also have
difficulties and needed to recruit many
of the car big cargo ships coming here
hannah i just want to follow up with you
also and ask you um do ukrainians
largely trust what they're hearing from
the government at this stage are they
happy with how president zielinski is
navigating all of this
ukrainians are very happy and never
trusting the government you need to
understand it in one of your videos the
journalists said that ukrainians doesn't
trust the government that's a little bit
uh tricky thing because ukrainians never
made
um the president never perceive the
president or the government and the gods
whereas the tar so for us it's always
the complaints about the government
because for us that is democracy the
question is that if you see for example
the percentage of uh population that
trust the armed forces it is more than
70 percent uh the same when you speak
about other uh agencies involved in the
protecting security and defending
ukraine that's much more important uh in
terms of zelimsky um you we know uh his
background so definitely a lot of people
saw that he is not ready for the
significant uh security threats and
challenges uh what uh the practice
showed as for now he managed more or
less with the situation uh
would we like to see better surely as
any citizens we always would like our
presidents to um act even better perform
even better than they're doing but
that's normal
pavel what what else does it play here
when it comes to what president putin
wants i mean is this simply about
ukraine or is there a lot more at stake
well it's cool for mo for russia it's
clearly not just about ukraine ukraine
is just part of the big big picture
moscow is putting maximum pressure
on the west on the united states and its
allies to for them to make concessions
and agree to a new framework of security
in europe that will give
russia a buck much bigger say in what's
happening in europe and
apparently it's believed that in in if
such a
solution happens ukraine will just fall
into russia's lab as an additional bonus
and this heightened pressure will
continue
and actually there are more risks
really than just simply around ukraine
there was an incident in the sea of
ahuts which russia considers its all
with its territorial waters and deployed
a sizable naval force there because the
sea for the kind of bastion where
russian strategic nuclear submarines go
and patrol from there they have to
they're intended to shoot
intercontinental missiles nuclear
missiles at the united states and they
should be guarded there and there a
russian frigate used live
depth bombs against what they thought
was an american intruding
submarine apparently no one get got hit
there no one was injured but that's what
might happen there are also reports of
bus throughs between russian planes and
american planes in the mediterranean
where russia deployed also a
anti-carrier
force and there are three nato carriers
right now in the mediterranean an
american one harry truman a french one
an italian one and they're anti uh and
they're russian cruisers that are
intended to sink carriers so and there
are no ukrainians in the mediterranean
no ukrainians in the sea of achotzka and
the baltic and there there could be
direct uh
skirmishes between american and russian
militaries as if the situation continues
to be tense or
even if there's a de-escalation it will
get tense in six months and that's
already a direct russian-american war
possible i mean not that it's very
possible but the threat of a
escalation happening somewhere through
is very high and at least it's very
dangerous situation
it's not just upright
william i want to take a step back and
look at another aspect of the diplomacy
um president biden has been resolute for
a while now in saying that the us will
not send troops to ukraine that that is
not an option ukraine is not a nato
member so that means there's no treaty
obligation to do that
but
doesn't that in some sense take away a
key point of leverage when it comes to
the u.s negotiating with russia about
all this
so first of all
the united states has had troops in
ukraine as trainers um in east in the
western part of ukraine near lavif java
reef training ground the united states
has had
up to 200 at a time
armed forces military people active duty
military in ukraine so so that's that's
been there they're not there now
um but that's first of all second point
on on u.s forces is
ukrainians have not asked for nato
troops or u.s troops to fight beside
them that is the ukrainian government
has not asked for that
um the third thing is
president biden has been very clear and
i would even say aggressive about moving
u.s forces from the united states
to nato to eastern europe to the
the border with ukraine to demonstrate
commitment and to demonstrate to
mr putin and to ukrainians that we're
there very much in force we're there in
with military units a couple of the
units that i used to serve in when i was
in the army um are there on the on the
eastern flank uh of of nato
and the fourth point is
if by some reason pablo pointed out a
couple of places where u.s and russian
forces uh already been in close contact
dangerously close contact
if that should happen
uh or if the if the russian forces
should for some
terrible reason attack poland or attack
the baltics that will trigger nato's
response and that will mean the u.s
forces uh will be engaged there's
absolutely no doubt but one last point
on this
this is why negotiations
are so important one of the areas that
uh that the russians have suggested and
that the americans and nato have have
agreed to
is looking at ways to avoid these kinds
of clashes looking for ways to to be
sure
that the exercises
that nato conducts or the exercises that
russia conducts are are observed or
transparent or notified in advance
those that's an important part of the
negotiation that that can take place
anna we just have about a minute left i
want to ask you very briefly how big are
concerns in ukraine right now about the
potential humanitarian impact of an
invasion
we already have two million internally
displaced people in ukraine and you've
never heard about ukrainian refugees
luckily so considering that ukraine is
quite a big country and a lot of our
local administration are preparing that
in case of open and big aggression can
be additional move of the people that
can be a certain humanitarian crisis but
nothing uh that for example european
union saw because of the syrian refugees
uh we are trying to accumulate as much
as possible of the local forces to uh
cope with this situation and the
strategy for the national resilience
adopted last year is one of those to
deal with such cases all right well we
have run out of time so we're going to
have to leave the conversation there
thank you so much to all of our guests
william taylor hannah cellist and pablo
felgenhauer
and thank you two for watching you can
see the program again anytime by
visiting our website aljazeera.com and
for further discussion go to our
facebook page that's facebook.com
forward slash aj inside story you can
also join the conversation on twitter
our handle is at aj inside story for me
muhammad jim jim the whole team here bye
for now